[Music]
are you someone who who tackles action
scenes occasionally I love that stuff I
mean I had an old I have an older
brother who who you know he played a lot
of sports knighted everything he did and
when I was younger he would throw me in
goal cuz I'm from Canada so he would
throw me and all of his friends would
throw pucks at me and wait a minute they
would throw pucks at me no no they would
you know they would shoot puck say I was
gonna say that's not hockey what they
were doing they would put me in a net
and throw objects at me so so they would
make you the goalie and they would fire
pucks at you so that's pretty you could
get hurt yeah and then when my brother
decided you wanted to Thai boxing I was
his personal punching bag for 10 years
because I couldn't and we couldn't
afford a punching bag so
it's any sack fill it with sand again
they're lying to you Nina afford a
punching bags
so we wasn't you yeah your parents just
said use your system yeah that's how it
was it my house yeah all right so but
yeah but but mostly you I would guess
you use doubles and stuff like that on
Vampire Diaries sometimes but I love it
I mean I I love doing stunts I love
getting I was a gymnast or I love doing
all that kind of stuff
and you know I have a lot of friends
that are stunt guys and so I kind of
hang out with them along bring them
everywhere I go we practice stuff it's
like I'm so funny because I you know say
the wrong thing but obviously very
attractive very talented I just don't
see you as someone who's like kicking
ass do you know what I mean that's just
not what I that's not the vibe that I
get I'm kind of I'm a little insulted
actually I mean you don't think I can
guess the purpose of this show is to
bring people out and insult them I just
that's not the vibe I get I don't see if
you'll say cue I like you as an action
star it's not something that I think oh
I will be Angelina Jolie one day and I
will kick some ass and I have the
stuntmen
with me all the time to prove it
literally you travel with stunt men
women travel with stunts I do guys come
on get out here yeah yeah these are my
they've been living back there that
these are your stunt men guys and what
do you what did you want to do something
today I'm gonna prove it to you and
we're gonna stage a little scene where
I'm at a bar you're gonna hit on you
sure it's a bar or a zoo well let's see
okay so well you're actually you want to
do a scene right now okay all right okay
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so set the scene we're in a
bar and you're obviously a beautiful
woman and this is these guys with me
yeah these are the these will be your
your gang this is my gang okay this is
kind of how I roll to four guys in black
t-shirts that's kind of what I do and me
in a business suit well you can see me
around and so what happens I walk into
the bar and you you do what you do what
boys do whatever you would do all right
I'm gonna come in and and I think in
this scene you'd be very attracted to me
okay
why are people laughing at that I don't
understand okay here we go and I walk in
you're drinking alone and I come in with
my standard line I didn't know angels
flew so low come on I think you're
interested no one's ever turned this
down okay look I said no so please back
off thank you gotta give cones II
advanced all right
[Music]
[Applause]
I still don't see you as a stunt person
sorry that was fantastic nina dobrev
thank you so much right back